hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild and enjoyable game uh from the uh
first round of the semi-finals of the
grand prix uh feeder grand prix 2022 it
see car nakamura vs richard rapport and
it's a game that really shows you uh it
doesn't matter what the engine says if
you if you play well if you continue
playing well then everything will you
know work out in your favor so let's
dive straight into it the game lasted
over five hours it's a very very
complicated uh
hikaru has the white pieces and he opens
with d4
uh we have knight to f6 we have c for e6
knight to c3 and d5 so the queens again
they declined this on the board unlike
for the queen's gamut accepted we've
seen in the previous game uh c captures
on d5 e captures and bishop to g5 now so
nicely developing uh
the bishop here we have c6 strengthening
the d5 pawn and the queen to c2 so this
is all very very standard stuff the
reshefsky variation we have bishop to e7
and e3 now preparing to develop the
light square bishop as well knight b to
d7 and bishop to d3 we have knight to h5
now
black wants to
rush some exchanges here so uh
the bishop trade is offered we have
bishop captures on e7 queen captures and
hikaru castles queen side
so what will rapper do first knight to
b6
uh we have h3 now a very important move
you want to play g4 as black is uh uh
preparing some some g5 knight to g7 and
bishop to f5 action so you want to
prevent anything from from coming to f5
so here we have g6 knight to f3
knight to g7 now you would be very happy
if you could play bishop to f5 so he
prevents it with the g4
bishop to e6 and now knight to e2
shifting the knight over to f4 to put
pressure on the bishop and rapport also
castles queen side and here there are
some games where knight to f4 was played
but kikar plays the prophylactic king to
b1
and it is now as of move 15 that we have
a completely new game
uh so let's see how a robot continues we
have king to b8 uh and rook the c1 now
the other rook might be coming to d1
might be coming d1 uh we'll see what
happens we have knight to e8 uh shifting
the knight over to d6 and knight to for
now uh knight the d6 and hikaru plays a4
maybe with some ideas of later on uh
playing a5 to take advantage of this
knight so knight d to c4
uh trying to trying to trick cover a
little bit uh but not really he car does
play a5 but this um this kind of
blunders a pawn that upward plays queen
to b4 and now if you're not careful if
you capture the knight and then you play
knight to a3 check and of course the
pawn is spin you lose the queen
so after this queen to b4 move we have
queen to c3 offering a queen trait but
now a rapper just picks up the pawn so
queen captures hikaru captures and
knight capture so now black is up a pawn
but he cover has some very active play
here so knight the g5 putting a pressure
on that bishop on e6 and here we have
rook d to f8 saying that okay you're
very welcome to capture this bishop but
if you go after knight captures on f6
we're gonna play f captures and then
your f2 pawn is hanging but still maybe
f4 and then we continue playing against
the weak e6 pawn uh but here he cover
plays something completely different he
plays bishop captures on g6 this is the
move i decided to put on the thumbnail
because it's extremely complicated and
super enjoyable now uh how you want to
play this is you want to play h captures
and g6 this was not played in the game
but i'm just going to show what happens
if it's captured now knight captures
bishop here uh rook f the g8 not
capturing if you capture here then a
knight captures on g6 attacks both of
the rooks and after let's say rook after
g8 we can capture here a rook rook
captures and yes you have two knights
for a rook uh but the the two connected
pass pawns will be simply too strong so
white will be completely winning here so
what you will have to do after knight g
captures an e6 is just move the rook
rook after g8 and now the game continues
uh with white having a very very solid
game knights the c5 can be played and so
on so this is what hikaru could play but
instead after this um
uh bishop captures on g6
we have knight to b3 first rapport goes
after he carries rook and now again what
can his car play well again best maybe
his knight captures on h7 and it makes
sense you already grabbed this pawn grab
this one and now you're attacking the
rook here so
not all that much um uh black can do
because if you ever captured then the
bishop is hanging as well so here we
would see something like rook the c8 now
rook c3 attacking the knight and after
let's say f captures and g6 we're going
to play rook captures on b3 rook
captures an a7 knight captures on e6 and
white is having a very very enjoyable
game but after knight the b3 this is uh
to too complicated uh hikaru plays
knight f captures on e6 he grabs the
bishop
we have f captures on e6 and now knight
captures an h7 so this is how he does it
eliminates those pawns and now he
created two connected pass pawns on the
king side uh what can adapter do well
first rook after g8 he goes after the
bishop bishop back to d3 and now he
captures the rook so knight captures on
c1 king captures on c1 and rook to g7
attacks the knight so now he carries
down the exchange but he does have two
connected past pawns here so knight to
f6
of course you do not want to lose the
knight black was ready to give up uh one
of the rooks for for the knight in
bishop and here rapper has to play rook
to h6 chasing away the knight without
allowing hikaru to just
start pushing those pawns however he
played rook to f7 and this is where
things start to go um uh poorly for for
rapport uh as hikaru now plays g5 if the
rook uh remained here then this would
this would not be possible uh in the
line that we've mentioned uh for example
after knight to f6 if you just play uh
rook to h6 now the rook is guarding the
g5 square so obviously we can't play
that so rook to f7 g5 by hikaru now look
at this h4 h5 h6 the pawns are just
marching forward and there's not all
that much you can do if you play rook h4
to stop the h pawn we're going to play
f4 we're going to have a very impressive
pawn chain here and we'll still keep a
better position but rapper decides to
give up the rook he was already uh
getting very low on time we have g
captures on f6 and now rook to f8 ready
to pick up this pawn and now hikaru just
starts pushing his past h pawn so rook
captures an f6 h5 and rook to h6 he
stops the past h pawn and now hikaru
starts by bringing the king into the
game as this is what you always have to
do when uh getting into the end game so
king d2 our plan of course is to get the
king to g5 kick away the rook and
continue pushing the pawn and black has
to do everything black can to prevent
this so king c7 it's a race of kings
king a2 king d6 king of three king the
e7 we have king to g4 and king f6
stopping the very dangerous king g5 but
now rook to h3 we're gonna kick away the
king with rook f3 check so knight to c8
rook f3 check king to g7 and now even
bishop to g6 now we can move our king
hopefully if uh
if we can do this the pawn is nicely
protected we just win the game so knight
the d6 uh controlling some very
important squares here and uh also uh
after after he cover plays king to g5
what can black play here well you can't
move the king otherwise you lose the
rook you can't move the knight here if
the knight
leaves control of the f7 square then
rook f7 check and again you lose the
rook so what can robert play here uh
there is but one plan he has a two to
one advantage here so he has to start
pushing those pawns create a pass pawn
here and then maybe his a pawn will be
able to do something against the
hikaru's powerful position so that's
exactly what he does he starts by
pushing a5 and hikaru now finds a a
beautiful plan rook to a4
rook to f4 he wants to play f3 grab hold
of this square
and then the knight will be pretty
pretty useless and then he can start
by pretty much doing anything so of
course that upward prevents this the
idea is if you start by b5 then uh f3
and then let's say a4 we're going to
play rook to f6 pick up the spawn
everything is just falling apart and
there's not all that much you can play
here and you're not
nearly uh fast enough to to do something
by pushing those spawns b4 rook captures
on e6 we're gonna play a3 rook captures
here and now of course uh you can't
capture here because the bishop is
covering the b1 square uh but if you
play uh pawn to a2 then we get rook to
d7 check king the f8 and now king to f6
and even though you can get the queen uh
you're getting checkmated the black king
is uh stuck here and after of course
rook captures and g6 h captures on g6
now a1 queen uh rook to d8 is still
checkmate so a beautiful line but it
doesn't work for rapport unfortunately
so instead after rook to f4 rapport
cannot continue pushing he has to play
knight to e4 check bishop capture sunny
for d captures rook captures and now we
have rook to f6 and now we have this
rook component game where there is
pretty much a one move that's winning
for hikaru it's not an easy one to find
so feel free to pause the video and test
your end game skill while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on pushing the pawn
all the way to f4 and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show that's
the congratulations uh but just that to
show you how tricky it is let's say you
play rook f4 and you want to win the
king and pawn end game let's say
captures captures we're gonna play b5
and now it's a really really a terrible
race h6 check king h7 king f6 a4 we of
course want to create a pass pawn king
captures b for now we're going to play
f5 a3 captures captures f6 and now a2
pawn to f7 a1 queen black queens first
the white queen second now queen
captures on d4 and you're not gonna win
this with white so hikaru finds the
absolute strongest move that is f4 but
rapport created some counter chances
rook to f5 check allows him to go after
the the b pawn and then he can start
pushing so here rook f5 check king the
g4 rook the b5 going after the pawn and
rook captures on e6 we have a4
or captures doesn't matter because uh
both moves will have to be played so
rookie seven check king to h6 now comes
rook to e8 uh we have rook captures on
b2 rook the h8 check king to g7 and rook
back to a8 going after the pawns or
upper defense it would be five and look
at this he carries up a pawn but it's
very very tricky hikaru pushes e4 now
comes rook to a2 we want to defend our a
pawn and start pushing our b pawn so
rook a7 check king to h6 and now uh we
have rook to a6 going after this pawn or
rather just pinning it so we can start
pushing this pawn
but just king back to h7 here rapport is
creating a trick because if hikaru
captures this then we're we're just
gonna push a3 and that's not good rook
to a6 now b4 and now the b pawn is much
too
uh too close to the queening square so
instead hikaru repeats rook to a7 check
king h6 we have rook to a6 again and
rapper repeats again so will we see a
repetition here not really hikaru is
just um
gaining uh gaining a little bit of time
he starts with e5 uh that's of course
what you have to play so rapport
continues pushing b4 we have e6 and
before pushing e6 uh you have to check
that it works and this is obviously the
first move that you will check because
uh the the e pawn is the closest to the
queening square okay the h-bone is also
the same distance but there's a king in
front of it so you should check if this
works then you should play this hikaru
checks he says it works and he plays
ponte e6 we have b3 by rapport and now
again
what do you play here uh well there are
two good moves king to f5 and rook to a7
check if you if you try something like
f5 then that's not going to work i'm
just going to briefly show you why not
let's say rook g2 checking f3 we attack
the rook there's this very nasty b2 move
now if you capture black gets a queen so
you're going to have to play rook to b6
now comes a3 and now after king captures
on g2 we play a2 and now
it's a very very tricky e7 uh we're
going to play b1 queen black white will
have to give up the rook queen comes
into the game e8 queen and now queen
captures an f5 and again a very very
tricky end game where maybe white can do
something but there's no need to to
allow this so instead hikaru plays king
to f5 also you will not um uh you know
have to calculate all the time what
happens if black check checks you uh and
here rapper uh just plays uh rook to a1
uh so if you play b2 then we just play
rook to b6 and you can never move that
b2 pawn again so instead rook to a1 and
now we're preparing b2b1 and he however
prepares for this of course he plays
rook to b6
and now he completely paralyzes the
queen side you can't push this pawn
because this pawn falls you can't push
this pawn because then again the pawn
falls not much you can do here so rapper
plays rook to e1 he stops the push of
the e pawn but now king f6 we have rook
to e4 going after the f4 pawn and now
while you could play f5 uh hikaru
calculates perfectly that e7 is just
enough uh rook captures an f4 check king
to e5 now rook f1 hoping for this uh
promotion so then we deliver check and
pick up the queen so hikaru plays king
to d6 and now rook to e1 we stopped the
promotion king the d7 and now it seems
that the game is over but rapport finds
the very resourceful c5 and now what do
you do well
obviously we can bring the queen into
the game but here the problem is if you
capture capture and captures uh there's
three pawns here against the rook and
you will not be winning this with white
so instead hikaru captures the pawn you
could also play d5 hikaru decides to
capture the pawn now comes the rook d1
check king to c7 and rook to e1 going
after the pawn hikaru again defends rook
to d1 check very very nicely defending
king to c6 rook to e1 and now hikaru
says all right you can have your e pawn
i'm gonna go after the queen side pawn
so rook to b4
and now okay you could capture the e
pawn
but rapper first plays b2 you have to
give up one of the pawns probably both
but
this way at least rapport gets his rook
behind maybe the past a pawn
so here rook captures on b2 rook
captures on e7 and now rook to a2 and he
was in this position on move 71 that
rihard rapport resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
problem is it doesn't matter how you
defend with the rook here or rook here
you're still down upon and it's a very
very important pawn just to give you an
example king b6 now this pawn promotes
king h6 so we're gonna play c6 king
captures an h5u equalized in material
but c7 and that's it rook to c4 we're
gonna play king to b7 now uh getting
this spawn all the way rook to b for
czech king to c6 and now after rook to
c4 check of course we're gonna play king
to d6 rook to d for king to c5 and
that's it once the rook goes to d1 uh
wants to deliver this check and pick up
the pawn we can just play rook to c2 and
that's it so of course arapat knows this
after rook to a2 he resigned to the game
and a brilliant brilliant victory for
hikaru in round one of the semi-finals
we'll see if rapport will be able to
bounce back with the white pieces
tomorrow uh and who will we see in the
in the finals for now uh the leaders are
levon arunyan and hikaru nakamura will
this change tomorrow we'll see so great
game hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank sorry about that
in this position feel free to pause the
video jonathan kemp fork and tributions
to my channel kanji and david bryan for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
semi-finals until they end
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend